hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game between alpha 0 and
stockfish now we already said that we're
gonna cover some more of the games from
this match and I think 200 games were
released out of those 220 are of extreme
caliber and we've already seen I think 3
games that were played completely out no
or 4 games that were played completely
from scratch and two games that were
played from a certain position from an
opening book this is one of those games
that was played using a position from an
opening book I chose this one for this
video as it features the caro-kann so
it's very interesting an advanced
variation of the caro-kann it will be
very enlightening to see how alpha deals
with these kinds of positions we've
already seen how alpha treats the French
now we're gonna see how it translates
the advanced caro-kann and also I would
just like to briefly interrupt the game
for for a short announcement YouTube did
their annual thing where they forcefully
unsubscribe people from channels there
are algorithm decides whether maybe
they're not active enough or maybe maybe
they think they're just don't don't want
to be subscribed so they unsubscribe
them against their will so feel free to
pause the video here and check if you
are still subscribed to the channel for
those of you who have done this and you
are still subscribed congratulations you
are definitely an excellent subscriber
in YouTube did not do anything to mess
with this and for those of you who were
perhaps unsubscribed against your will
you are more than welcome to join back
the team and join the rest of the
excellent subscribers so that being said
let's return to the game we already said
that we do have a nice advanced
variation of the caro-kann so we have e
4 c 6 d 4 D 5 and E 5 the advanced
variation of the caro-kann is on the
board and this is still everything all
the moves are from the opening book that
we have to e3 e6 those of you who are
perhaps joining us in this alpha versus
rockfish match for the first time the
openings that were played here were used
in the TC ec 2016 the top chess engine
competition so they wanted to see how
alpha and stockfish eight would treat
these positions 92 we have
Knight to d7 night two G to f3 Knight to
e7 Bishop to e2 and Queen to c7 so this
is everything still from the opening
book we have castles of alpha and there
were a couple of games in the database
and there are now that have reached this
exact same position and there is one
game where a six was played but the move
stockfish chooses the f6 move
immediately going for alpha center is
the first of its kind so already on move
eight we have a new position on the
board so let's see how alpha deals with
this of course you can capture here but
black will just recapture with the Jeep
on blacks planets the Castle queenside
and black would have a really massive
center here he could use the semi open G
file to already start a start some sort
of an attack against the White King
black would have an excellent position
here so what Alfa decided to do after f6
is to sacrifice the e pawn the central
pawn by playing c3 c3 you'll see why why
c3 now we have F captures on e5
stockfish who decides to capture the
pawn Knight captures on e5 Knight
captures on e5 d captures and Queen
captures so stockfish grabs the pawn but
the seat in the the pawn being and c3
now does not make the b2 upon a target
so here alpha is free to make a move
without worrying about the b2 pawn but
it's not like alpha worries about pawns
rook to e1 challenging the Queen's
position on e5 and here the Queen
retreats the C's to c7 better now then
after one of the bishop moves and here
Bishop to h5 with check so alpha
sacrifice the pawn now he has to make
make it count
so how will alpha gain any any sort of
what's the word any sort of compensation
for this sacrificed pawn here okay this
comes with check you could block it with
g6 that's something you don't want to do
as you already have a light square
bishop here that will pretty much make
your entire pawn structure look the
bishop look like part of the pawn
structure so here nice to g6 if you try
to block with Bishop to g6 then you get
better
the g5 of course the white will not
capture and allow black this open H file
so here brush up to g5 and after Queen
to d7 now the v6 point is under attack
Queen to d7 after the ponies defendant C
for already challenging the black centre
end with the black King still being in
the centre white will simply gain too
much for this pawn so after Bishop to h5
check we have Knight to g6 and now comes
G for attacking blacks light square
Bishop Bishop to d3 but p4 is also
possible but then Knight captures pawn
captures and the the white rook will
make quick work of the doubled black eye
pawns so G for Bishop to d3 and now
comes nice to be three attacking the
bishop here with Bishop to c4 and here
comes the move that well it's always
hard to analyze alphas games but here
comes the move that I really enjoy and
it's nice to d4 here you have to see
that black has all of his central pawns
on light squares and he also has a light
square bishop so if the position reaches
some sort of an endgame then this Bishop
will be a bad Bishop and alpha-alpha
doesn't want to allow this bishop to be
traded for this night so nice to d4 this
comes with an attack against the e6 pawn
we have E 5 attacking off as night here
and now comes b3 and like we said a
stock which would very much enjoy if he
could give up this light square bishop
for this night but for the moment it is
not possible because after pawn captures
Bishop to f4 check would win the Queen
the king is in check and black will lose
the Queen here so after B three we have
Bishop to a6 retreating with the bishop
and now comes Bishop to f4 and excellent
move by alpha because here if black were
to be allowed to push efore and create
this massive central pawn chain then
black would have an excellent position
here with Bishop to f4 alpha doesn't
allow it and now you cannot capture or
push efore because well you can't
capture because the the King would be in
check but you can't push efore because
you would wonder your queen so here we
have queenside castle now of course
there is a threat of capturing either
the worship or denied but simply push up
to g3 you could go Bishop captures on g6
immediately remove the defender of d5
pawn only then capture but why give
black the semi-open h-file for attack
there's no point in to it and alpha does
not sacrifice upon Terry to grab back
the pond so quickly so Bishop to g3
still keeping the tension here and now
comes Luke to e8 we have a four by alpha
expanding on the Queen side we've
already seen alpha do this very often
mess up your pawn structure on the King
side push the pawns on the Queen side as
far as possible and good things will
happen that's how that's how offer does
things work a kink the b8 stock which
wants to bring the King all over to a8
to improve the safety of the King and
now comes before at some point b5 will
be an idea and that will severely weaken
the d5 pawn first Bishop to d6 now not
allowing this pin to exist now e4 and
capturing the knight will definitely be
a possibility but now Knight to f5
putting pressure on the bishop here but
also attacking the g7 pawn and here we
have as b5 now definitely is a threat
Bishop to c4 if you don't play Bishop to
c4 let's say you do this then like we
said b5 will be a very nice threat pawn
captures Queen after Sun d5 and now
there will be simply too many threats of
pawn captures here Knight captures here
Knight captures in g7 and Queen picks up
the bishop so a lot of threats here so
after Knight to a5 with Bishop to c4
now b5 will not come off as that strong
of a move as the bishop is already
protecting the d5 pawn but now Queen d2
alpha now has different plans for the
Queen King to a8 and now comes Queen to
g5 so a very nice position for for the
White Queen you can't kick her way with
h6 that will make the knight on g6 Hank
after this Knight moves for example
Knight captures then the Queen the
bishop and the rook will all be
attacking the e5 pawn and at some point
to win this Knight is either captured or
moved then both the Queen and the night
will be attacking the g7 point so
extreme pressure against Blacks position
but black is still up upon so let's see
how stockfish deals with this we have
looked to e6 and now adding further
protection to the d6 Bishop but also if
the knight is captured preparing rook
captures on g6 so here we have it Knight
captures on d6 by alpha look out for Sun
b6 and now Bishop captures on g6
you cannot capture here because Queen
captures on if I would win you the game
you have to protect your rook and after
rook here simply move the Queen and then
black is lost here so after Bishop
captures on g6 we have rook captures on
g6 now the Queen is under attack and now
comes Queen captures on e5 Queen Queen
captures Bishop captures two white
recaptures the extra pawn black head but
now rook captures sorry
first we have rook captures on e5 and
now comes rook captures on g4 now white
did not allow this capturing on g4 to
come with check so why did recapture
back the pawn here but the black now
capture the g4 pawn and black is still
up upon so you might think what is all
four doing here stock which is still up
upon and it's an opposite called Bishop
endgame so how is the alpha to proceed
here
well first f3 kick back the rook rook to
g6 and now comes a five and now when you
look look at this position like we said
this Bishop isn't all that great it will
be very hard for this bishop to gain any
activity okay that's the control this
diagonal but that that diagonal isn't
very important for the game at the
moment alphas plan is to bring this rook
over to a-1 to gain complete control of
the file but even with only one rook on
e5 what alpha already has complete
control of D of the only open file on
the board as it's very hard to imagine
that black will be able to challenge
alphas dominance on the e-file
but okay we have looked to f6 attacking
the f3 pawn but alpha simply doubles up
as it comes with huge tempo now of
course you cannot capture
due to back ranked weaknesses of course
this would end in a checkmate but then
again you can't prevent it by playing a6
making some room for your King as you
would still fall victim to rook to e8
check rook captures King a rope capture
sin after King to a7 now of course you
all see the
forced checkmate sequence the checks
King moves Bishop checks King moves and
now Bishop to be seven will be
checkmated the rook is covering the
entire bank back rank so after rook 81
now alpha increases his control of the
e-file and the stock fish doesn't really
have all that much to do we have looked
after eight trying to fix some
background weaknesses although there
isn't much you can do here and now King
to have to alpha simply starts improving
the position we have g6 now comes Luke
to e7 at some point alpha is planning to
push a six here when the when the move
will be possible and then black will
either have to push b6 and make a
weakness out of the a7 pawn or capture
here and then the bishop will be able to
attack the a7 pawn and also the rook
will be able to join in with the attack
so alphas plan is clear here we have h5
trying to push h4 in and here
h4 would be sort of an automatic but
alpha finds an even better idea
Bishop to e5 attacks the rook on h8 rook
H to g8 and now comes Bishop to g7
forcing this rook to move we look to see
it and now you can see with this Bishop
on g7 and this rook on e7 this rook has
to stay here all of the dark squares are
unavailable the rope is covering these
squares this were discovered so
basically the only squares the rooks are
allowed to go to they are already there
so black really has no useful moves here
and the bishop is still there on a light
square and as it often is is in games
with opposite colored bishops when this
bishop will be used to attack the a7
point the light square bishop will be
powerless to help as it only controls
the light squares push up to d4 now at
some point like we said a six will be
pushed and then this will be a very
powerful attacking tool for alpha with
Bishop to b5 and now comes King to g3
now alpha will use the dark squares to
bring his King all into deep into the
position
Bushra back to d3 with King to h4 and
now comes Bishop to f5 King to g5 this
is unstoppable
dr. simply has the
can see what will happen and now comes
Roxy to d8 Bishop to g7 now looked back
to see eight and now comes rope - II -
we have rook rook to d8 and now comes h4
again simply improving the position
waiting for blacks to make a move rook
back to c8 and now finally comes a six
you could you could also try and prevent
this by playing something like Bishop to
d3 but then after the rook attacks the
bishop the bishop will have to decide
whether it will keep an eye on the g6
pawn or it will keep an eye on the a6
square so the bishop will be overloaded
but okay we have a six here and now
comes B captures on a6 like we said if
you pull b6 then you're gonna make a
weakness out of the a7 point and here
the the planet would be fairly simple
rook to b7 threatening rook to e7 to
double up on the seventh rank and of
course after black stops this you will
play captures captures and then go look
- c7 and then the c7 point but the c6
bone will fall and slowly but surely the
entire black position will crumble you
could stop it with rook c8 but then the
bishop has to leave the defense of the
g6 pawn and then these pawns will fall
when you create two passports on the
King side the game is over but okay
after a sex with B captures on a six but
now like we said the dark square bishop
will be used to to attack the a7 pawn
push up to d4 we have King to b8 and now
comes the birth of captures on a7 we
have King 28 and now comes the should be
back to c5 we have King back to b8 you
don't want to allow the skin to stay on
a 8 as rook to a7 if this comes with
tempo that the king will have to move
and then this rook will come to e7 for
free and the black will be lost so came
to b8 we have looked to a2 going after
the e6 pawn but now Bishop to d3 and ok
so far this Bishop on d3 can keep an eye
on the a6 pawn and under g6 pawn but at
some point white will attack both of
these weak bonds and you black will not
be able to defend everything rook to d2
attacks the bishop bishop to be one
keeping around g6 pawn and now rook to
d1 forcing
the butcher back push up the c2 and now
push up to a seven check King moves and
now rook to e1 butcher moves back to d3
and now we have Bishop to b6 and like we
said if black allows this to come with
check then black will be lost after King
to be a true key seven comes with tempo
and now there is very little you can do
you have to prevent checkmate rook c f8
and now after check for King moves
Bishop moves you will go Bishop to H do
to keep an eye on this square and now
there is no defense against rook to a7
checkmate you will have to suffer severe
material was just to prolong the game
pointlessly but okay Bishop to b6 with
King to b8 not allowing rookie 7 to come
with check Bishop to d4 and now Bishop
to f5 black is still holding on but now
f4 again alpha simply slowly but surely
improves the position rook C to D 8 and
now comes Luke 281 again threatening the
ace exponent Bishop to d3 defending and
now rook to e3 attacking the bishop
we have Bishop to b5 and now finally
rook to e1 so you cannot go Bishop to d3
now as the D 3 square is defended by the
rook King to c7 black makes a move and
now comes King to h6 we have King to see
it and now comes Luke to e6 now the g6
pawn is under attack so if you defend it
with Bishop to d3 then the c6 pawn will
fall so you can do that so here
stockfish tries an active defense we
have Bush to a4 first Bishop to c5 the
g6 ball will fall at some point so
simply improving the position even
further and here King to b7 if you try
to push up the c2 to keep an eye on this
for a pawn again you lose the c6 pawn so
there is a very little point in doing
that so after Bishop to c5 ink the b7
trying to keep an eye on both phones on
the Queen side but now rook captures on
g6 we have rook captures and King
captors on g6 now the material is equal
alpha managed to grab a pawn but now as
you can see the DF 1 is a passport and
it's an extremely fast ball so here if
you try anything like maybe you want to
defend this pawn it's a way to slow
simply rook e7 check and after the King
moves
King attacks rook rook moves and now the
F pawn starts marching up the board and
it's all over
so after king g6 we have d4 stock which
tries the the final attempt with an
active defense Bishop captures and now
comes in the shop to see - with check
King characters on h5 and now comes c5
at these moves are now pretty much
pointless but it's you know stockfish
wants to go down you know swinging
Bishop captures on c5 and now King to c8
we have rook to e5 now alpha is up three
points rook to h8 check we have King to
g4 rush up to d1 check King to g3 look
to h7 and now rush up to d4 King to d7
we have f5 now alpha finally starts
pushing the F pawn rook to g7 and after
King to f2 unmoved 71 it was in this
position that stockfish resigned the
game or to be more precise stockfish
didn't resign stockfish just didn't make
any more moves rather it took him too
long to make a move so it's considered
that stockfish resigned but yeah even
though it's a really really fun game I
really like everything about this game
first how alpha sacrifices upon already
on move 8 then how alpha moves the
knight the d4 doesn't allow the the
light-square bishop to be traded for the
night and then this lights the light
square is really just a liability for
the rest of the game and how alpha uses
the dark squares to march up the board
with the king it's it's very impressive
so especially you know if you face if
you play the coral Khan and if you often
have to play the advanced variation of
the caro-kann maybe some of these ideas
you can also use in your own games so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it plenty more games between
alpha zero and starfish while we're
waiting for my Capablanca books to
arrive so really do hope you enjoyed
this I would like to thank Charles Baker
and Matthew Viet Minh Chris Picard KS
Dylan and the diamond plate Juarez for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos
you're thankful for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully what's a more
interesting content and yeah if any of
you are interested definitely do
check out the new merchandise it's quite
fun I am an excellent subscriber and
gesture to enjoy the show
so that's that thank you all and I will
see you soon